[音楽]
東風三国前々から思ってたんですけど
えっ
あなた甘いんですよ
こんなちゃん肇社長ですこっちですあの人によってはですね
おっからない人がいると思うんですよ腰が起こります起こらないんです
これはこんなお金ないんですよねあの結構付き合い長いです
思ったんですけどゴチさん起こらないんですよねベッツィー者をご覧いたりするといい
と思うんですけどやっぱ起こらないとストレス日目がちだと思うよね盾子ちゃんいつも
なんか
グッズバック2口やがされ言わずが食べたくのようなんですよだしちゃうけどグッチ方
はやっぱりよくないと思うんであればですよ
その怒ってる相手のためにも起こってあげるってすごい大事なことだと思うんでて僕
その場で発散する発散とは違いますそう
相手のためを持ってお互いのために嫌われる
重機があってはじめて怒れると思うので僕をこれすごい素敵なと思ってる
インターレーザーにして起こるといい気持じゃあないカオスんですけど起こることに
よって何がダメかなとかわかると思うんで僕起こることですごい大事だと思うんですよ
なんで今日のこの動画ではごっつたんでもう誰か怒ってこちらのためにも怒られた失敗
をした人のためにも今日は私が作った
ストーンの起こり方講座
やっていこうと思いますでこちらも典型的なを取れない人の例なんで
心でが起こりますよそんな子さんと体位を混ぜながら人をどうすれば誇れるのかごく
自然な起こり方を今日は皆さんに紹介していきたいと思いますでは見て予想
[音楽]
rar
あっはい
西しまーすいたしますえっ
全物はの先週だすって約束せた資料がされ今でき
あー強早番や酒がいません入っ
確認しておきます18年から気を付けますので
それから気をつけて弊社自治会内でする
[拍手]
[音楽]
おっ
失礼致します
部長先週提出予定だった資料が今できました
大変申し訳ございません
遅いんだよ
your でしたあ
会社辞めちまえ
大変申し訳ございません
会社ナメとるのか
をやめちまえ会社なんか言えますよね
ん
いいよもう
しています
me
いやいやまぁそれは別にいいけどさぁそその次のそのステージをそっからお前どうする
からそのやり方向けにで道ができると思うなお前
あっえっじゃあほとんどですよいいと思うから a な
まず気を付けておけ
[音楽]
いやまぁそれは別にいいけどさその次のそのステージを
いやそこはそれはやばいやお前だって思いますキャバクラん57店舗目でしょう前
指すべり空は行き過ぎだと思うんだよなまぁそれはやんだよ
立っ
par
うざーい
ウズん
ん
そうでつねーなー経済持ってませんすいません
th
ええええええ
コミュニティ悪いと言わねー
ん
おいしいねはい今日も頑張りなちゃん
うっ
[音楽]
を枝をど生えてんだよ
しています
4分
チェーンパイパンヌード
れるやっ大丈夫けどちょっきょうつけられないよねゴホンッ
一般みてくださいこれねこれはよるただものなんですよ心配がをもらったんですけど
すごいのは日本だよって範囲なくて言ったしかない後席にしろああ
全パの1095銭パーたから持って一音の嘘
ええええええ
女を会社にろって言うんだ
うーんまあ
うーん誕生会俺におねがー
ああああああ
年配生まれたねまぁ
誕生日室4年敗防男
4を
[音楽]
waa
ありがとうございます
そのプレゼントんですよおんぷくやを今年もいい家5くださいありがとうございます
だった
でございまー
うーん誕生日ありがとうございまーす
いや前場目指す誕生日と教
はぁ
そうします
全敗今年も h 0にしてください
[拍手]
プレゼンっ
うざうざ
me
あった
増えていますあっっ
me
[音楽]
入ってまーすあああ
えっ
ん
オセロ
me
dea
car
ana あああっ